there is something that she's commented
on which is
she's suffered or
went through depression after winning
her second olympic gold
why do you think this happens we you
often hear stories of great champions
becoming depressed after the olympics
there's a lack of purpose afterwards
right because you've done
in life what you set out to do you've
had a goal every day you woke up you
knew what your purpose was you knew what
your
you know what your day looked like you
knew why you were doing that
and all of a sudden you won and you got
all the fame and you're all happy and it
but then you wake up and you go
now what
i don't have a next and and also because
there was nothing for her there was no
there was no path set out for kayla that
said okay we're gonna you're gonna
become an ambassador a global ambassador
of judo
you know the ijf is gonna help pay a
salary the the usa judo is gonna give
you a salary here's what we want you to
go teach children we want you to go be
an ambassador for women we're gonna fly
around and and you know whatever it is
he's gonna give you a job and here's
what you're gonna do you know if you'd
like to take it there was nothing for
her like i remember doing the interview
at the olympics with her
and they said are you gonna compete in
the next olympics and i said no like why
she already two-time gold medalist what
what does three-time gold medalist do
for her nothing right it doesn't
motivate her to do it again
they said are you doing mma i said no
why would she do on me that's ridiculous
like she doesn't need mma she should be
able to make a living off of what she's
accomplished in this sport for the rest
of her life yes but what happens is and
what most people don't understand is
once you say i'm retired i'm no longer
competing in the in the sport of judo
you don't get a salary from usa judo
anymore which she was getting
i think she got like 72 000 a year from
from usa judo at the time
you don't get
a stipend from the olympic committee
anymore goes away
your sponsor like the new york athletic
club was a great sponsor for her for all
those years in fact she could have never
been the athlete she became without the
support of the nyc because i talked to
them when she was 15 i said hey i got a
girl that's really good
someday like if you invest in her now
i promise you she'll pay back for you
and they say and i remember the day she
won the olympic gold i called the guy up
and said hey i told you
so but yeah you know they can no longer
give you stipends because you're not
competing and representing them anymore
so that goes away
um all of your sponsorships and all of
your money that you would make from your
tv commercials or whatever that didn't
happen for her after the olympics
because judo is an obscure sport right
so she didn't have any opportunities for
that
at the end of the day she has no no
revenue coming in how do you live you
get a bonus of 25 grand from the olympic
committee or whatever for for winning a
gold but aside from that you're not
going to live on that money so
no purpose no goal right what am i going
to wake up and do tomorrow i don't know
so she has no direction and at the same
then at the same time she has no money
coming in
so everything shuts off so now it's like
where do you turn what do you do
you know and
that leads to
being depressed because yeah even though
i've accomplished all this stuff
i'm kind of lost in life like what's
next for me
and i guess you just have to ride that
out because
when you're a great human being great
champion
life has a way of
helping you find a way right i mean she
she's in mixed martial arts now but she
has a lot of stuff going on right
well her kids she she adopted her her
sister's kids so she's their legal
guardian now so that is her purpose
right raising raising these kids and
making them part of her family and
um she's fortunate enough that she has
enough money that she can do that and
she can give them a good life
you